we get bigger hype for series and I
don't the problem is that I don't know
what hype translates to for like profits
like there's hype help at all like
probably right because you can probably
sell more merch I mean it didn't help
change people man yeah well I wonder I
wonder how chainsaw Man released in
Japan I I don't know if it was on TV
what time start it was on because Japan
sometimes [__] [__] anime over and
they stick yeah I think chainsawanda was
on like most streaming sites from what I
remember okay in Japan as well
um so I think they did a decent job then
like compared to like some of the older
shows but I can easily see a world where
chainsaw man struggle to find a solid
demographic that really it's [__]
weird because it's just it kind of
touches a lot of I guess kind of
different niches that would appeal to
different kinds of people but none of
them are all like like epoxy The Rock
like you said you know the 50 year olds
are gonna show up you know what I mean
like like chainsaw man who do you who
you 100 targeting here because it's like
edgy teenagers is just roll just young
young adults probably 40 year old man
probably it's a little too weird for
them like you know what I mean like it's
it's such an odd it's an odd show that
appeals to I think just hardcore anime
and manga fans yeah which is great
because it's it's in a [__] amazing
show and I don't think anyone would
argue it's not but I think I I can 100
believe that it probably had a hard time
just selling itself to a demographic in
a way that would meaningfully make money
but is there are some franchises like
okay the biggest the biggest one that
has never made sense to me right
it's a Evangelion yeah I'm just like
why why this because if you look at the
history of like anime franchising uh in
Japan Ava was one of like the first that
had such like a massive hit all around I
mean we had like obviously like Mecca
before like Gundam and everything like
that but Ava was just everything
everything about this was seen
everywhere in July it was a cultural
phenomenon and I'm like the time it came
out and the type of show it was I think
if it ever came out today it probably
wouldn't be yeah but he like you look at
Ava and I'm like this doesn't look like
a marketable show you look you look at
what's happening on screen and you you
just see no one's looking at being like
more marketable than chainsaw man you
think so I think so because okay first
of all Max Max are great for money uh
number one because because you could you
can sell the max they're iconic uh
number two uh I think the main character
I think Shinji is way easier for sale
than Dengue I think oh no because I'm a
disagree are you there because as we've
learned from Pochi The Rock socially
anxious characters that are depressed
[__] resonate they do well dingy is
is too happy go lucky no no no and he's
too horny because you don't wanna you
don't wanna okay look look you don't
want to be that horny look you you need
to go with you know the the reason denji
works then she's the best mate denji's
not the guy you want to be denji's the
guy you want to have as your mate oh
denji Genji I feel resonates more with
today's audience than uh denji is the
guy that everyone wishes they could be
but they're too too scared to admit yeah
because that's okay you look at you look
at someone like uh mid area right good
good kid follows the rules oh oh I just
want to be a good boy nobody [__]
thinks like that anymore you know yeah
watch it like you you look at [__]
we're [__] grown ass adults guys you
[__] look at the you [__] look at
like teenagers now and they're like yeah
I'm a [__] dingy what do I give a
[__] about I don't know I actually don't
know I just want to touch themselves I
just want to touch some attention denji
definitely would subscribe to an only
fans if he had [__] income okay look
denji
I'm trying to make an argument for some
[__] I made up for a show I don't like
listen I think that Shinji being a
little [__] boy probably helped a lot
that was they had sex and Eva I think
right there's come on the hands or
something someone had sex but it wasn't
Shinji
I know this is through memes only it's
like yes I had to have that 30 second
sex scene where I show everything the
xinji like fell on top of a naked Ray
and still got no [__] like he's got no
hope bro yeah yeah but like I came out
wait wait when did they get 90s 1995 95.
what a horny year that was I can see I
can see why it worked I thought I think
maybe Ava might have like kind of banked
off of the whole like 90s OVA era of
just like I think anime fans in general
were just looking for more weirder out
there unique [__] yeah I don't think Ava
would be like Ava would not work today
yeah no way yeah I think it just came
out at the perfect time and it was that
one show that was like it's just also
Banger opening yeah of course yeah
it is
but like I think
that was one of those shows where like
it it came off a time where people were
looking for something that was like
weird and unique but still not so weird
that it alienated its entire fan base
and I feel like evil was just like kind
of right on the cusp of that
I think I think in terms of a you know
uh from the Japan perspective you know
the struggle of being a teenager who's
being told what to do and yeah you're
kind of struggling with that that's a
very I mean obviously that's a very
Universal concept but I think very much
so in Japan where it's uh I'm a teenager
and I'm I'm struggling with my identity
here I don't know where all my places in
the world and all the adults are telling
me to do all this stuff so I think
that's also a massive reason why I'm
successful yeah and again it was horny
um I think I think as well Ava just like
really grew from just like Word of Mouth
like I don't know this is all
speculation I've made based off only
watching One season and [__] yeah
because like I feel like Not only was
Ava like so like I think the people who
really liked it it started off kind of
small-ish and then it kind of Grew From
just a word of mouth because anime was
just getting more I guess
normal to watch in the late 90s and
early 2000s and then not to mention like
the countless number of like people in
the industry who like directly you know
looked at Avon was like that was a huge
influence or like you know that we took
a lot out of Eva and it's like I think
it's just like the combination of the
influential factor in the industry and
just the fact that it just came out at
the perfect time and it's just like
everything just came together with a
banger opening on top of that a cherry
on top there you go yeah because I I
think the big difference uh between
something like say chainsaw man and Ava
is that I think they just have different
demographics like period I think Ava has
I think the topics explored in Ava
probably
resonated with a lot of the older
working like uh generation in Japan at
the time where there was a lot of this
societal pressure
um once you grew out once you you know
graduated from high school and
everything
um and that kind of like story
um really resonated with the whole
generation of people in Japan and I
think that's one of the big reasons why
it became the massive hit that it did uh
and then 30 years later they became
Bocce fans
actually actually
they were once in their 20s Ava fans I I
would argue that I think Ava fans and
Bocce fans have more in common than
Bocce fans and uh chainsaw man fans oh
sorry then uh like are more likely to
have something in common than Bochy fans
and jeans yeah I mean yeah I I truly
believe that James a managed hasn't
found it's it's it's a die-hard audience
yeah that it appeals to I mean I I think
I think they exist but it's only in the
manga form right now yeah maybe I mean I
I don't know I also think it's harder to
sell merch for chainsaw man because yeah
yeah it's just even you don't do
anything yeah hey I mean a chainsaw man
is just a little bit edgier it's a
little bit it's a little bit too weird
for the regular yeah yeah and did you
see Kyson I feel is that perfect Middle
Ground from you know there's uh let's
say my hero Academia the kind of like
the poster child of like safe kind of
like he is like it's got a very similar
vibe to like gants almost like very
horny yeah very gory all right chainsaw
man yeah oh yeah
[__] [__] no [__] dick with foxes
but like I think Gans came out at a time
when edginess was was very much in
demand I think edgy edginess is of
course not as in as it used to be I
think people are kind of over oh again
because like all these shows banked off
of the [__] edgiest period of anime
which is the 90s OVA period like those
were some of the edgiest [__] shows
ever I feel like there will always be a
space for edginess
but it's not as in the Forefront as it
used to yeah I think it goes in and out
of being in the mainstream popularity
but there'll always be a demand for edgy
shows because like in terms of like Peak
popularity because like I'm waiting for
like I'm not sure already exists but
whatever this generation's Mirai Nikki
will be uh because every every okay here
hear me out hear me out every generation
every generation has a [__] show that
for some reason when you're a [__]
teenage kid my hero slapped so hard all
right for me it was like for me like the
the progression goes elf and leads yeah
uh Mirai Nikki yeah uh akame got kill oh
God right yeah and I'm like what is what
is this generation is going to be I've
prayed to God it's not Jason
man
is good or are we just saying that like
we used to say with Mirai Nikki
thank you
oh my God they had so much Gore like
like do you remember the phase where uh
you're like guys adults uh guys anime
actually for adults and it would always
be the first 10 minutes of Elf and
leaders
always elf only to be like yo people got
killed and it's bloody and it's violent
yo this [__] stops yeah let's let's hope
it doesn't happen
oh yeah chainsaw man is not in that same
category because it is actually it's
actually a good shot is [__] amazing
I just yeah like I said I think we just
think it's like a little too cold yeah
yeah a little too edgy to right now for
it to crush mainstream yeah yeah I hope
it does though I hope it does I [__]
hope so too I haven't read further on
the manga apparently it just oh my God
second half is Juicy I don't know if
this is a controversial tape don't
[__] animate a new intro outro every
time just give me [__] more episodes
yeah I'm gonna be real yeah I mean okay
I kind of feel like they did that that
was Overkill yeah that it was it was
Overkill it was awesome yeah but it was
too much yeah okay because here's the
thing right Attack on Titan obviously
gory obviously edgy right
um but do you feel like that was
successful because it just never kind of
like tried to be a Shonen or try to
Market itself as a young audience and it
went here is a mature kind of like story
right from the get-go yeah maybe perhaps
yeah it's hard to say because attacker
Titans success is a really weird one
it's a bit of an anomaly yeah I mean but
I think no one would say it isn't
deserved yeah
um but I mean yeah even Japan it's still
huge Titan is [__] massive yeah and
it's kind of in its own bubble in that
right where like no other show is kind
of like it or done as well as it in
Japan it's just very weird it's very
awesome I feel like that's just because
that's I mean marketability aside if you
have a good story like Attack on Titan
then at the end of the day you're gonna
get fans and people are gonna try and
find a way to sell it it's also like the
Titans are pretty [__] iconic yeah
even if you don't know Attack on Titan
you've seen a Titan yeah yeah and you're
like well not in real life obviously
well you might have seen one like you
don't know you did they're so easy to
spread and I I don't know I feel like
it's
yeah it's serpazal it's it's so it's
such an interesting it has it has such
like noticeable like imagery and like
recognizable imagery that no other show
looked like or will probably ever look
like right yeah so that definitely helps
whereas like you know as vividly as
Vivid like visually chainsaw man was
like you know it's not exactly the most
like outlandish like unique visuals when
it comes to like character designs or
anything like that right so I think
maybe that might be another aspect where
it's like it's not as instantly
recognizable I feel like maybe
Chancellor man just hasn't had enough
time yeah I feel like I feel like it
needs to cook just a little bit longer
let them cook yeah I'm I'm [__]
hoping that the next season when it
comes out whenever the [__] comes out
that it really does I'm just saying as
someone who's right ahead the second
half of Chainsaw man is [__] wild
like yeah I just want them to be
financially [__] God I want them to
print money yeah just yeah we get more
yeah true